hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba this
is Brad our Lambert Colin Farrell's
brother well Brad he likes his comic
book movies and this got sent to us the
Justice League Friends trailer it's the
intro of the show friends with the
Justice League cast over it it's gonna
be really funny guys Warner Brothers
themselves definitely not the case let's
watch this 30-second spot yes
hey that last shots not bad either no
it's not you know I really appreciate
about the Justice League
they've taken all the notes of not
having humor and they are slap debt and
humor and all of my face so much humor
in the Justice League when I watch like
BBS a Man of Steel I did feel that
feeling of yo lining up just a tad bit
please and I feel like there's a lot of
people's complaint and now they've
really taken that into account
my only concern cuz here's all I really
care about with Justice League I don't
care for it to be this really monumental
meaningful film I do I just want to walk
out the movie-going that was some solid
popcorn fun I had a great time I'll
watch it again sure I might walk away
with a couple criticisms and I my one
criticism I feel like I might walk away
from it with a little too much I still
feel like it's gonna be a lot of fun
there's some new jokes in here you know
I want friends and yeah the pitchfork
yeah you know well I think adding Ezra
Miller and Jason Momoa Cass will add a
lot of humor I feel like the saving
grace cuz Batman's cracking some jokes
hey that's where it kind of throws me
off a tad bit but but you know if you
have like the newer characters like
flash and Aquaman and even cyborg yeah
making a few jokes here and there that
would be like not as like a weird
transition because they're new
characters they're really showing Batman
cracking a lot of jokes yeah what do you
think I mean you excited for Aquaman and
all that yeah I'm very excited I think
there's adding Aquaman and flash cyborg
and obviously seeing Wonder Woman again
after the Wonder Woman film just broke
all kinds of records was a phenomenal
film they did a really great job with
patty Jenkins at the helm we saw in that
film that they took a different approach
as they did with man is still and her
PBS very brightly colored upbeat humor
fun yeah and uplifting and yeah
motivational if you want to go there it
was a totally different vibe than what
we've seen before from the DC film yeah
it was very motivating I want to get a
sex change they they knocked it out of
the park
you're seeing that in this trailer too
and the other spots we've seen yes very
colorful the humors there they're just
having fun yeah and you mentioned it
earlier this is an apocalyptic kind of
scenario but they're still finding a way
to have fun yeah which could work it
could I would like there to feel like
these guys are kind of worried instead
of like we got this what do you think
about Ezra Miller I mean you're a fan of
the flash you got your STAR Labs shirt
[Music]
no I'm excited I really liked his work
in the past and I think he's gonna bring
a lot of energy to this film a lot of
witty sarcastic kind of yeah comments as
he said with the friends line in the
beginning he seems more socially awkward
oh yeah you know like I know that grant
gustin's interpretation on the CW show
is fairly awkward yeah when it comes to
like women but this guy seems like he
just resorts to jokes because he doesn't
know how to just communicate sincerely
he's uncomfortable and I think we talked
about it earlier I think from what we've
seen thus far of the flash the scene in
BBS is he's very new to his powers we're
kind of seeing that so I don't think he
has his full arsenal yet
yeah his abilities which is cool as he
mentioned in the one trailer he just
pushes people and runs away because I
don't think he has the full breadth of
his abilities yet which is exciting you
know what I think is gonna happen now
that you just pointed out that flash was
in BBS because I remember coming Louis
is the key that's yeah yeah the official
trailer the last release the heroes one
started off with Louis seeing Superman
and that dream sequence I know I said
flashback it was 6:00 in the morning
give me a break I'm thinking maybe we
misinterpreted that maybe Louis is the
key to them finding Superman again to be
part of it just I think that's a great
idea washe was being like yeah we need
Supes yeah I mean Louis to fight yeah
that's a great idea
so I like that line and one thing to
calling this trailer friends I really
feel like this the marketing for this
has been like we're really promoting the
dynamics we're really promoting the
interaction we're promoting the
chemistry and the bond this team seems
togetherness which I'm really happy
about because I'm like yeah that's gonna
be the main
I feel like Joss Whedon's stepping in
yep if he gets a writing credit that
means a lot of things that probably
changed her and the last final version
of this film I have enough confidence is
gonna be at least a solid entertaining
time I'm really not looking to go in on
this movie and criticize this [ __ ] out
of it I'm not and I don't a lot of
people are yeah I think comic book fans
have to just go and enjoy mashup movie
yeah like what is there to complain
about yeah just go enjoy yourself you
get the fun dialogue quips from Joss
Whedon you get the cool action stuff
from Zack Snyder what more would you
want hey you know we'll see well save
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification about more importantly
follow Brad our Lambert on Instagram my
friends let's do this a wonderful
Instagram yes you got photos of his
beautiful face and then you got photos
of things that he takes of other things
and he got photos of women that he does
not have relationships with saved your
butt